c'est extrêmement facile à trouver
vous survolez la côte méridionale de la
chine et dans la bête quand on entre de
petits nuages léger comme une bouchée de
pipe vous apercevez un îlot d'une
douzaine de kilomètres presque collé au
continent surchargé de bâtiments
environnants et de bateaux arborant
autant de pavillons qu'il existe au
monde deux pays ayant une marine ou des
relations chez les grecs
c'est hong kong reliques exigu et
provisoire de feu lempire britannique
vous atterrissez et le dépaysement
commence parmi une population encore
plus dépaysé cloud depuis longtemps le
cosmopolitisme atteint ici un degré de
concentration inconnus ailleurs le
passant auquel vous demanderai leur dans
une rue qui pourrait être une rue de
londres ou d'alger vous répondra en turc
en pakistanais en anglais en arménien ou
en espagnol il peut même arriver qu'il
vous réponde en chinois que leur n'a
aucune espèce d'importance
rien n'étant plus changeant que le temps
ni plus illusoire que la durée dans le
quartier administrative de victoria
l'anglais ce crochet lui avec cette
différence qu'il y fait moins de
complexes
le français qui a mis en batterie son
appareil photographique enregistre des
indiens qui mangent avec des baguettes
dans des bâtiments qui rappelle le
rond-point de la défense et le chinois
qui vient de passer la frontière du
continent communistes se croient en
suisse dans un pays de banques et de
libéralisme intégral apparemment
dépourvu de police
et toutes occupées d'achat de vente des
changes de combinaisons financière de
promotions commerciales et immobilières
de l'autre côté de l'étroite enclave
continent tels de colons les normes
dragon de la chine rouge et là
curieusement immobile il lui suffirait
d'allonger l'une de ses pattes de
quelques centimètres pour broyer cette
dernière petite perle de la couronne ou
de souffler un peu plus fort que
d'habitude pour éparpiller comptoir
marchés actions et obligations au vent
de la mer de chine
mais le dragon bouge pas et il a l'air
décidé à retenir sa respiration jusqu'en
1997 date qui marquera la fin du bail
britannique
curieusement sur le statut de hong kong
et des territoires adjacents et l'une
des curiosités diplomatique du monde
moderne
et
oh
coût
oui
cela dit nous ne sommes pas moins en
chine cela soit à quelques enseignes à
la multiplicité de ses restaurants et de
ses boîtes à l'européenne qu'on ne
trouve plus en europe à ses hôtes but
qui viennent des surplus londonien assez
pousse-pousse ou à ses dragons
folklorique maintenus en activité sans
limite d'âge par la bienveillance des
syndicats d'initiative
le
nous sommes en chine se laisse voix est
de merveilleux visage d'enfant
à cette manière de tourner en rond pour
s'habituer à vivre sur une île
assez personnification du bien et du mal
qui se bat comme d'habitude sans
résultat
ok avec un arbitre
vous êtes aussi à cette propension à
l'immensité pacifique qui étire le
paysage chinois
et
à une certaine douceur à une certaine
lente
la beauté mystérieuse des regards ou
assez noble phase de vieillards auréolé
de raphia équipe au jeu contre
rétribution avec un sourire finement
gravées dans l'ivoire des ans
oui nous sommes en chine malgré les
apparences le béton n'a pas encore tout
à fait solidifier le paysage la nappe de
gaz des civilisations 20 industries yen
n'a pas encore tout recouvert l'histoire
subie quelques ralentissements dans les
ruelles des vieux quartiers
je
sur les eaux du port où se voit toujours
de ces étranges navire la proue surélevé
aux ailes de chauve souris qui embarque
encore les curieux pour l'un des
derniers passages de la poésie
à hong kong l'infini est au bout du
chenal